tonight A group of Republican senators
are demanding a 72-hour review period
before the Senate votes on any border
deal as Fox News learned some of the
details Fox News correspondent Lucas
Tomlinson has a reaction from the White
House
LT election year politics Will Factor
heavily into the fate of this Senate
border Bill to put it mildly the house
Speaker says it's Dead on Arrival Donald
Trump says he doesn't support it here's
Tennessee senator Marsha Blackburn the
president could close that border if he
wanted to close the border he will not
close the border we can pass all the
laws there are and if they are not going
to follow the law then why are we
passing something now here's what's in
this proposed Senate border plan
mandatory Detention of all single adults
mandatory shutdown of the Border once
the average daily migrant encounters
hits 5,000 and the shutdown would not
lift until daily encounters reduced to
less than
3,750 encounters per per day and in
short here's the plan of how many
migrants would be allowed into the US
under the Senate deal
150,000 per month and 1.8 million per
year that's about the population of
Phoenix President Biden reacting in a
statement saying quote for too long we
all know The Border's been broken it's
long past time to fix it what's been
negotiated would if passed into law be
the toughest and fairest set of reforms
to secure the Border we've ever had in
our country it would give me as
president a new emergency authority to
shut down the Border when it becomes
overwhelmed many Republicans think The
Border's already overwhelmed based on
the historic number of Migrant
encounters last month Victory cannot
come soon enough under crooked Joe Biden
our country is dying our country is
dying our borders open and gushing it's
a big gushing wound we have no choice
within moments of my inauguration we
will begin the largest domestic
deportation operation in American
noice we have no choice because this is
not sustainable we need to seal the
Border alog together it is absurd to say
that 5,000 people a week is is
acceptable stopped it in the past a
recent ABC News poll says only 18% of
the country approves of the job Biden is
doing on the border a new Gallup poll
says Biden's approval rating last year
was the lowest of president since Jimmy
Carter after skipping the Iowa caucuses
in the New Hampshire primary President
Biden will be on the ballot for the
first time in South Carolina where he
will be this
weekend and as the Senate border deal
shakes out Elon Musk is blasting Biden
in front of his tens of millions of
followers on X Trump also weighing in on
true social posting quote there is a one
100% chance that there will be a major
terror attack because of the Border
crisis okay let's do a little right
lightning round here Jason shall we on
day one of this Administration who ended
all Border Construction yeah it was uh
President Joe Biden uh the the the best
the best president in my lifetime was
president president Trump and he did it
with the existing laws lock down the
Border get rid of the rewards and
incentives re reject amnesty why don't
you just try enforcing the current law
and the other thing that's just driving
me nuts is that the president of the
United States right now will not talk to
the border patrol they haven't talked in
like two and a half years talk to
Brandon Jud in who's in charge of the
border patrol Union do it the border
patrol T you don't need this other piece
of legislation if it was such a great
piece of legislation how come it's not
out there in the light of day for all of
us to read it that this thing is so
fundamentally wrong it should be wrong
and should be rejected just from the
fact that they're touting and selling it
but they're not showing you the text day
one also stopped remain in Mexico day
one also reinstated k and release okay
let's read that tweet from Elon Musk
quote no laws need to be passed all that
is needed is an executive order to
require proof before granting an asylum
hearing that is how it used to be Lisa
so why don't they just do it if there is
serious as a prison fight when it comes
to stopping this flow at the border
which suddenly after three years after
taking office the Biden Administration
is taking seriously because they see the
pulse well I mean this is what he wants
to happen that's why he's not going to
stop it I mean he started this crisis
with his pen he could end this crisis
with his pen and instead of doing that
what the Senate wants to do is codify
this Invasion into law I mean you saw
those numbers 150,000 illegal immigrants
a month over 1.8 million a year that's
an invasion in perpetuity if the Senate
gets its way so that's what he wants and
I love how he says oh I need this bill
so I can shut down the Border if it's
overwhelmed what do you call over six
million illegal immigrants that have
come in the country more than 33 the
population of 33 States right he already
has the emergency of authority to shut
this thing down if he wanted to but not
only does he not want to but he's
fighting States like Texas who are
trying to get the job done so this is
going exactly as planned this is what
Joe Biden wanted Tommy I want to get
your reaction to hakee Jeff he's the
House minority leader he's blaming ding
ding ding Republicans for the Border
crisis at a certain point uh we are
going to have to publicly call the
question of our Republican colleagues in
a variety of ways uh when it comes to
doing what is right for America's
national security interest and uh for
fixing our broken immigration system or
we just going to make it clear that
Republicans have no interest in dealing
with the Border issue they'd rather try
to weaponize it for political
purposes Tommy always judge people on
their actions and not their words all I
know is in Texas the governor there is
trying to put up razor wire in the most
heavily trafficked areas to stop this in
some way since the feds won't and yet
the Biden administ ation fighting him
tooth and nail on that this whole border
deal they want the perception that
they're taking the Border seriously
without actually doing anything to take
the Border seriously but as you said
they see the polls they know that this
looks bad for them right now but I've
always maintained Democrats they're not
stupid they see the long game of this 6
million plus illegal immigrants already
in this country so they're okay in my
opinion with taking a little heat on
this now because they know that this is
going to pay out for them for years and
years to come because the next stage of
this is going to be amnesty voting
rights 6 million plus since Biden took
office probably closer to 10 if we're
being honest you don't have to win the
hearts and minds of the American people
if you've got millions of people that
are indebted to you and that is the
long-term plan do not be fooled they are
not stupid maybe Sinister maybe very
strategic but not stupid pay attention
and when presidential elections come
down to a few thousand votes in six or
seven swing States it can make all the
difference in the world to your point
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe subcribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else